bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors ce troisième
mandat d'alpha condé et comparer en
toute force par ses opposants
qu'en pensez vous c'est vrai que à son
âge et vu les propos qu'il a tenus
jusqu'à présent il était présenté comme
le président qui ferait entrer la guinée
dans l'année zéro de cette
démocratisation
c'est ainsi qu'il a été perçue lorsqu'il
est élu pour la première fois il avait
il à vis et d'un opposant historique
déjà pour le pour le aussi tué il a
énormément fait pour la démocratisation
de son pays mais depuis qu'il est devenu
président c'est vrai que les conditions
de son élection ont été contestés celle
de sa réélection également et la réforme
de la constitution qui l'a opéré
ressembler à quelque chose comme un
instrument pour rester au pouvoir au
delà des demandeurs qui avaient été
fixés donc c'est très mal perçu au sein
de l'opposition mais dans son cas
effectivement les gens font bloc pour
qu'il soit réélu
également on rappelle que alpha condé à
82 ans soit en opposant lui 68 ans
cellou dallen diallo son principal
opposant n'est que propose-t-il pour
contrer alpha condé ils proposent
l'alternance pour l'instant tout ce
qu'il propose c'est que la limitation de
mandat soit effective que il a déjà été
premier ministre c'est pas un nouveau
venu hélas il a dirigé la banque
passerelle au niveau de la guinée est
aujourd'hui ils souhaiteraient vue que
lors de l'élection la première élection
d'alpha condé il avait fini quand même
plus de 40% des suffrages au premier
tour
il ya eu beaucoup de temps entre le
premier et le second tour et il a
finalement été battu aujourd'hui il
estime qu'il pourrait prendre sa
revanche et le chef de file de
l'opposition en guinée
c'est un poste qui aujourd'hui créée qui
a une valeur dans la hiérarchie du pays
donc il à ce rang là mais je pense qu'il
est il voulait plus encore d'abord se
positionner en tant qu'opposant
historique et candidat sérieux à la
présidentielle mais également un cap et
le retard qu'il a pris par rapport au
mouvement
la société civile notamment le front
national pour la défense de la
constitution qui descendus dans la rue
ces derniers temps et qui a porté le
flambeau de la contestation sociale en
guinée mais parce qu on rappelle aussi
que alpha condé cellou dalein diallo si
je me trompe pas se sont déjà affrontés
en second des rivaux de longue date qui
se sont affrontés en 2010 et 2015
ces derniers jours on constate que des
heurts ont éclaté entre militants des
deux camps est ce que vous craignez de
graves débordements dans ce contexte des
défis d'élections présidentielles tendu
comme cela est déjà arrivé dans les
précédentes élections
malheureusement ce n'est pas une
hypothèse à exclure
c'est une hypothèse même qui est réel
parce que au-delà de la rivalité entre
les partis politiques
il ya un vrai relents de guerre tribale
des rivalités tribales qui pourrait
déboucher sur de la violence et les
forces armées les forces de sécurité de
façon générale sont souvent là pour
mettre de l'ordre elles ne mettent pas
de l'eau avec du potentiel c'est très
violent par moments la répression donc
le risque est là aujourd'hui d'assister
à la fois à une implosion ethniques mais
surtout à des violences policières et
militaires sur les populations civiles
qui descendront dans la rue soit pour
l'un soit pour l'autre des candidats à
ce qu'il y ait compris au sein de la
capitale et dans certaines régions des
fiefs qui sont des fiefs politiques mais
plus défié ethniques avant d'être
politique et dans ses fiefs l'oeil n'est
pas facile de mener campagne
si on est dans si on est le quotidien
d'un groupe qui n'appartient pas la même
ethnie ou qui n'a pas les mêmes sa
pointe ans politiques ceux qui habitent
dans le quartier où la région une
dernière question louis magoar keumayou
la guinée est le deuxième pays de
provenance des demandeurs d'asile en
france depuis le début de l'année est ce
dû à la détérioration de la vie
politique selon vous il ya un peu de
cela
l'histoire politique de la guinée fait
que c'est le premier pays
parmi les colonies françaises d'afrique
occidentale et même d'afrique d'afrique
des gens c'est une colonie française
d'afrique subsaharienne avoir dit non à
de gaulle lors du référendum qui avait
organisé pour savoir s'il fallait rester
au sein de la communauté franco
africaine
c'est à dire 62 ans le pilier en 62 ans
d'indépendance aujourd'hui il ya
malheureusement beaucoup de trafic sur
les documents c'est l'une des choses
dans ce plan l'ambassade de guinée en
france il ya beaucoup de trafic de
documents qui font que y compris au
niveau des ministres et au niveau des
douanes de l'asie beaucoup de personnes
utilisent le passeport de la guinée pour
demander l'asile en france
donc ça sur le plan des statistiques ça
fausse la donne mais de l'autre côté on
peut pas nier que sur le dessus sur le
territoire lui-même il ya énormément de
violences politiques il ya beaucoup de
misère
il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui estiment
que leur avenir n'est pas dans leur pays
qu'ils émigrent d'abord dans les pays
voisins puis par moments se retrouve en
france ou dans d'autres pays européens
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai enjeu social
les pistes africaines n'ont pas encore
fait un enjeu politique
en europe on le voit ça devient un sujet
politique très important dans le débat
au moment des élections
merci beaucoup signé magloire keumayou
je rappelle que vous êtes président du
club de l'information africaine